gillet au coude bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin on le disait dans un rapport
publié hier lohan d'amnesty
international accuse donc israël
d'apartheid quels faits principaux
rapporte l'omg pour pour appuyer ses
accusations
écoutez malheureusement les rapports de
amnesty international se concertent
concentre autour d'un terme et qui n'est
pas adaptée à la situation
et là il va les trouver des d'aidés et
de prêts v caisse le terme d'apartheid
est très utilisée est utilisée à ce qui
colle à 1 concerne israël et
les faits sont
plus ou moins c'est qui est
son et
des faits existants concernant la
situation en israël mais et ils sont
utilisés uniquement autour de ces termes
ce qui enlève du sérieux et de ses
rapports et on essaye de progresser par
exemple et
les arts palestiniens qui sont dans
l'autorité palestinienne et
dans les territoires dessus c'est et non
pas des
nationalités formelle mais c'est lé cas
quand d'israël après les territoires et
des mains des jordaniens et en plus
c'est que les arabes et israéliens aussi
haut le palestinien qu'israélien comme
les appelle pour sa part et
ne bénéficient pas de tous les droits et
parce qu ils ne servent pas dans l'armée
alors il pourrait
donc il faut quand même se poser la
question pourquoi il n'est certes pas
dans l'armée parce qu'israël n'ait pas
voulu mais ils n'ont pas voulu que les
arabes et des ddd jérusalem est et non
pas la nascar en terre israélien niveau
il faut voir qui est en israël il ya une
différence entre citoyenneté et
nationalité
par exemple
l'union soviétique même en russie je
pense et les juifs sont considérés comme
nationalité israël il ya une différence
enter cela israël a proposé et la
citoyenneté et israélien aux arabes
de jérusalem est mais comme il se sent
qu'ils ont préféré garder leurs et
nationalité jordanienne ils ont ils ont
bien sûr refusé mais maintenant il ya de
plus en plus qu'ils acceptent et au bout
de trois ans
des cinq ans qu'ils sont là
cette nationalité aux citoyens
israéliens pour l'instant un statut
spécial et a été et a été créée pourrait
donc il faut voir
si ce qui est demandé ce qu'israël est
accusé il s'agit peut-être de quelque
chose volontaire de la part de
palestiniens est ce qui est intéressant
aussi
ça demain
déjà il faut dire par exemple que la
conférence de presse était à jérusalem
donc dans un pays d'apartheid est qui et
qui maîtrisent droits de l'homme qui est
contre et l'activité et des organismes
des droits internationaux vous vous
imaginez vous imaginer qu'une telle
conférence de presse n'aurait pas liée à
à jérusalem
de cet état et ce qui est ce qui est ce
qui est donc c'est intéressant aussi
qu'un ministre
à lespignan il serait rien si vous les
arabes israéliens et à et
faye déclarations contre est contre et
contre cette définition donc vous vous
imaginez dans un pays d'apartheid
ministres arabes amis l'histoire et dans
le gouvernement dans le gouvernement sud
africain du temps de l'apartheid et
c'est très très dommageable très très
dommageable qui est une institution qui
a fait beaucoup d'un bon travail est
partout une idée fixe syrie israël et a
écrit un livre d'un centre d'une
centaine de pages tout simplement et
pour trouver une façon littéraire et
plus que quelques uns plus que
scientifique ou plus que deux points de
droit de la régie et initiations pour
justifier un terme et qu'ils utilisaient
qui est utilisé et
et pour conclure on peut comprendre
effectivement il ya effectivement
c'est sur ce terme apartheid qu'il y a
aussi des désaccords puisque
les rédacteurs du rapport à eux mêmes
disent qu'il ne faut il n'y a pas de
comparaison finalement avec l'afrique du
sud et qui se sont basés sur le terme
appareils comme le définit la justice
internationale
c'est une question du terrain et quand
on écrit un
document légal de centaines de pages qui
doivent trouver
des
problèmes des droits de l'homme qui
équipe qui se pose si elle a
très bien aussi présente
et 2
dans l'east et internationale même si le
rapport est un cri par la section
anglaise là il faut voir aussi et la
politique interne intuit et par exemple
au fait que notre organisation human
rights watch a commencé à utiliser ce
terme est donc ce qui est intéressant
ici c'est la politique intérieure des
organismes et des organisations et qui
s'occupait à 10 ans des droits de
l'homme
là ils deviennent ils deviennent par les
organisations politiques selon vous il
ya une part de militantisme dans ce
rapport c'est ce que vous nous dites
bien sûr s'il s'agit d'une action
politique il y en a malheureusement de
militantisme gay du bon militantisme
rossi et quand on veut défendre des
droits de l'homme partout dans le monde
mais il faut quand même voir que ces
gros rapport se concentre de plus en
plus et depuis des années si israël par
exemple amnesty international a était
dedans dès une fois et d'essayer
d'écrire
rapport concernant l'antisémitisme et là
on arrive à l'antisémitisme et ils ont
refusé en disant ou du havre ont
j'écoutais ya tant de problèmes dans le
monde dont peut pas écrire sur tout mais
écrit israël sa rampe est donc on peut
comprendre la colère israélienne et et
les sujets des droits de l'homme mérite
quand même un traitement beaucoup
beaucoup plus sérieux merci gideon coûte
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france je le rappelle vous
êtes journaliste spécialiste du
moyen-orient